هذه هي الصور الاولى لقريه روزا
الاوكرانيه بعد القصف الروسي تقول السلطات
المحليه هناك ان الهجمات طالت محلا تجاريا
وبجواره احد المقاهي اين اجتمع عدد من
المدنيين خلال مراسم عزاء لاكاني توفي
هناك وقع هجوم للعدو على منشاه للبنيه
التحتيه الحيويه في قريه روزا بمنطقه
كوبيانسك كان السكان في احد المقاهي حيث
اقيمت مراسم عزاء لمواطن قروي قتل العشرات
للاسف في هذا القصف
العنيف تمر الدقائق وتتراكم الجثث الحصيله
اثقل عددا ووقعا على السكان عشرات الوفيات
وبين الضحايا طفل يبلغ من العمر ست
سنوات كنا في وسط المدينه وسمعنا انفجارا
قو
ث لنا ان شي ما حدث في قريه روز علمت
لاحقا ان والدتي كانت
هناك هي ليست قريه كبيره لكن غادر اغلب
سكانها بعد الاحتلال
الروسي 30 ك هي المسافه بين روز وس التي
تقع على خط المواجهه في منطقه تتقدم فيها
القوات الروسيه لاستعاده الاراضي التي
خسرتها امام القوات الاوكرانيه العام
الماضي يعد هذا القصف الذي نفذته موسكو من
اكثر الهجمات الدمويه منذ اندلاع الحرب
وادان الهجوم من اسبانيا الرئيس الاوكراني
فولوديمير زيلينسكي الذي جدد نداءه للغرب
لامداد بلاده بمزيد من الدعم
العسكري